Congressman
Kinzinger, it's good to have you with us.
What do you make of this Mishegas?
Look at the mess.
I think my biggest worry
just for the country
is not really the ballot after ballot.
And that's just democracy.
That's a process.
It's everybody's learning
kind of house rules now.
It is. What is Kevin willing to give up?
Because I think what we're seeing in
some of these,
we don't even know
what a lot of these rule changes are.
But for instance, one person
to vacate the chair
it's going to create chaos,
as we've been talking about.
Here's
the thing that I think we have to take.
When you talk about the five or six
that are kind of never Kevins,
what's their motivation
so of the 21 that are voting against
Kevin, a significant number of those
like they really believe.
I would disagree with that,
but they believe this is a way
to get to whatever their end goal is.
There are a number of people,
particularly these five
or six, that enjoy being in this position.
They relish
being the ones standing up, being the ones
kind of throwing a wrench in this.
And that's what I think the concern is, is
if they end up being only five, that's
probably for them even a better situation
because they get more attention.
Look at like Matt Gates
know, nominating Donald Trump.
And I think I know some of those folks
and I can tell you
they enjoy
being the five of the six people
that are going to deny
Kevin a speakership.
But it doesn't even have to be
because it's Kevin.
It's because they can be the ones
to do it.
And the idea of that, you might get
some of them to at least vote present
So this can finally resolve itself
I think it's possible
if you get to like ballot 50 or 70.
But I think by then I think enough
and this is kind of what we have to now
start watching, which you guys have been
discussing is how many folks and the say
in the middle generically and your average
kind of Republican member of Congress
is going to be worried about
what's been given up.
They're going to realize that
at this point you're really picking
a person over the health of the party and
by extension, the health of the country.
And you start floating
alternative names once alternative names
start getting floated by, we'll call them
the regular members of Congress,
for lack of a better term.
I think Kevin's done at that point.
Then he just has it's the problem
with some of these folks that have pledged
only Kevin, I understand the purpose.
It's like, hey,
we're as committed as you guys are,
but you have to have an out
because this could grind on forever.
And I don't think
Kevin can win in the long run.
So so I was going to say, you know,
Congressman, well, that assumes that.
So this is the 20 right left to say
they've been offered something.
The toothpaste is out of the tube in this
right So how do you put it back in?
Yeah, right.
So how do you put it back in now and say,
you know,
Congressman, your point is like
we're going to get somebody else.
But but the 20
if you're Chip Roy, these folks
you're going to say, well, wait,
we want our chips.
And we just we just
we just negotiated this.
The new person is going to come in and
say, that was the old guy, not with me.
So you know, because I know look, I think
you're I think you're completely right.
I don't know how let's say let's just
use Scalise as an example.
Let's say he comes forward and says,
now I want the motion to vacate the chair
not to be one person
they're not going to go for that.
And that's why
I think it's still not likely.
So I don't want to get people
kind of moving around on this.
But there is still a possibility,
especially as this drags on,
that you end up coming to this idea
of a consensus candidate,
an acceptable Republican, the Democrats.
The big question, can you get somebody
like AOC to vote for a Republican?
That's not for me to answer.
I think it'd be tough for him.
And then enough Republicans that say, like
we've seen in some of these statehouses,
let's have
a kind of a coalition government.
I actually think in the long run,
that would be good
for healing the institution of the House.
But how I mean, David Axelrod,
how likely is something like that?
Because the Republicans who would vote
with Democrats would could pay
a big political price for it.
Yeah, Adam, I mean, you'd you
would be someone to answer this question.
I mean, my feeling
is that in this political environment,
that is a tough decision for Republicans
to make in the Republican
who takes the the job to make.
I mean, I I'm with you.
I think that would be good
for the country.
It would be good for the institution.
It would be a way of breaking
the fever that you've fought to break.
But the
question
is, does the politics allow for it
or do you open up the door to, you know,
civil war in the primaries again?
Well, look,
I think if you look historically,
the politics doesn't allow for it.
But we're in a completely unprecedented
moment, at least in our memories,
where now I mean, as you have five people
keeping Kevin McCarthy ultimately
from the speakership, you could have five
that create a coalition government.
Put yourself in the mindset
of some of these members of Congress.
Let's say they come from a Biden district.
Let's say they've made a mental decision
that this is their last term
and now they have an opportunity
to kind of stand up.
Look, it's
not going to be a Democratic speaker.
And I think that has to be clear.
But an acceptable Republican
that creates a level playing field
and that kind of a speaker
could actually create an institution
that actually works.
So if you put yourself in the mind,
you only need five or six people
to say it's a historic opportunity
to do something to heal this institution.
I may not be running again.
And even if I am, I think maybe
in two years the history will judge it.
Well, Congressman Kinzinger,
how how many of those people are there?
I mean, they sound like unicorns.
How many are they actually do they exist?
Yeah, they exist.
I mean, you've heard Don Bacon,
for instance, kind of float this idea.
Right.
Don Bacon is a great guy.
Don Bacon,
you know, represents his district well.
He obviously is a military guy.
There are people with his kind of,
you know, resume sort of there
in the in the House of Representatives
that I don't think we're there yet.
I don't think it's
going to happen tomorrow.
But as this thing drags on, particularly
as they get concerned with
these institutional things
and again, Americans have to be thinking
what are we giving up for our country
so that one single man
can become speaker of the House?
And and I think
as that gets into those people's minds,
that might trigger something.
My sense when Congressman Bacon floated
that was it was in part to put pressure
on this recalcitrant group
to understand that there was a time limit.
And if they if they pushed down this road,
that they might end up with a situation
like that.
But executing it,
it just seems difficult to me.
You're saying five Republicans would join
the Democrats to elect a speaker.
Is that you're
I think there's any number of ways
this could go down.
I think let's say you take Fred Upton,
name has been floated.
He's a great guy. I'll just use him.
I don't know
if he's actually interested in doing it.
But Fred Upton, let's say
his name is put up.
You can get every Democratic vote for him.
And his agreement with the Democrats
is I'm just going
to create a level playing field
and then you get five Republicans.
It's possible
that that's how it could get done.
Again, I think we have to go through
a number of these iterations until people
realize it's doing real damage.
But I wouldn't rule it out.
And I think
it's a small percentage chance.
But I do think, you know,
when we were talking
about this possibility a month ago,
it's certainly more possible
now than it was a month ago.
Scott, Adam and Scott Jennings,
I have a question about your
your views on the tolerance
of these members of Congress.
You know,
they've gone through a couple of days now.
They've adjourned until tomorrow.
You know, who's to say anything
productive is going to happen tomorrow?
Then you go through the weekend
and then we're into next week.
At what point do you think fatigue begins
to alter the judgment
of some of these folks?
I mean, it's easy to be, you know,
intransigent today or it's easy to say
I'm I'm all in on some outcome today.
But by Tuesday or Wednesday of next week,
I was curious about your views of
of their of their stamina for this.
Well,
I fit for the average member of Congress.
They're already there.
They're ready for this to be done.
You know,
you had family here. It's the weekend.
There's a lot of pressure there.
You know,
none of them will tell you on the air.
They're not going to come out and say,
we're just tired.
We need to go home,
because obviously you have to put up this.
We're here to fight front.
The question is,
then who's going to give first and if you
look at the five or six.
From what I know of them,
I've worked with them.
They enjoy being in this moment.
They enjoy being in this position.
And so fatigue is certainly heading now
and it's going to get stronger.